so what are you doing for the rest of
the day
I'm preparing for the next game he had a
day off
he'd been in London before but he told
us he'd never seen the sights we took
him up onto this it's a giant Ferris
wheel that overlooks London and is right
on the south side of the Thames so you
can see the houses of Parliament Big Ben
we were up in the London Eye for I guess
45 minutes so he didn't look out the
window
just it wasn't interesting do you ever
stop thinking about Chess sometimes but
right now I was actually thinking about
Jess
and you were thinking about specific
moves or yeah I was thinking about
something specific in my preparation for
my game tomorrow